on this episode we come to a very very
special place
this is
Guerry be everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 140 of
the ask gary vee show super excited to
be here in the streets but not really a
little elevated in New York City
downtown New York obviously a lot of you
at this point have heard the buzz around
the incredible unbelievable century 21
mural commemorating 9/11 just it's a
real honor to be here and doing this
show something I'm sure I'll look back
on for a long long time and maybe
watches 10 20 30 years from now maybe
watch this with my grandkids tell them
about the history of the tragic events
that happened out here but this
incredible piece of art as Street art
graffiti and things of that nature
become bigger and bigger parts of
culture when I saw the incredible events
that transpire down here especially the
Patrick Ewing Carmelo Anthony thing in
the corner I reached out to my my dear
friend Isaac in the who is the co-owner
of century 21 I said hey I want to do a
show nearby so I'm gonna sneak you in
here by the way what about this outfit
Andy this is legit looking good looking
good thanks mother
I want you to tell the vaynernation a
little bit about yourself a little bit
about this project I'm gonna push you
off not over wrong and I'll continue the
show you got it you got it
basically 9/11 century 21 was destroyed
the tower fell on this building and this
whole building was completely destroyed
we were closed for nine months we almost
went out of business and we decided that
we would stick it out here because we
were here for 53 years and we don't want
the terrorists to beat us so we've stuck
it out we were the only store open and
then for many many years it was a thin
line for going out of business
and finally this area became better than
ever it's much better than it was before
2001 so mr. brainwash approached us and
said listen give a little give a little
context in mr. brainwash burn a quick
little bio for the people that don't
know mr. brainwash is a very famous
street artist
and he lives in LA and he's moving to
New York and he also did the exit to the
gift shop which is a academy-award
documentary about Banksy and he
approached us and he said listen I want
to get back to New York I'm moving to
New York from LA I want to make the
people proud and happy and change the
whole vibe of the city I want to do a
positive tribute for New York City
representing 9/11 and we said of course
we will lend you our building to do this
of course we also wanted we're very
civic-minded and to tell you the truth
of and they did the mural people were
crying people were riding on and
memorials on the bottom thousands of
people came hugging me kissing me thank
you for doing this first and they kiss
you on the lips the cue ones yeah that's
the story basically won't you tell you
know so obviously you can imagine this
means a lot to me but you'll see the
connection point a minute once you tell
for five seconds is a very
entrepreneurial business show little
story of your family's history as one of
the great iconic retailers in the region
that I also grow up grew up in great
question
we were 54 years old our my father and
my father's brother established the
company and basically what they had was
they had small mom pop stores all around
the city and then one day they decided
sell them all and open up a discount
department store so how did the name
century 21 come there was a World's Fair
in Chicago and they had like a nap cot
Center and abcott Center was like the
store the city of the future and it was
called century 21 City so my father said
let's make this the store of the future
century 21 by the way we got it before
the real estate so they can thank God so
that's how it started and and you know
one thing that I just want to give you
one last shout out that I think
everybody would love is you know you're
not a fourteen-year-old teenage girl but
you were just snapchatting in the corner
talk to me about your personal
relationship with all this new
innovation well what's your gut feel I'm
gonna tell you what it is
all our competitors Lowman snap-ins
Filene's sims all went out of business
they all started 54 years ago the
problem was they
change with the times we're still here
we want to be relevant we know that
social media is the way to go we want to
hit them over heels we want to cater to
them otherwise if we don't do that we're
gonna god forbid go the way of our
competitors so we want to stay one step
ahead of the group and that's one thing
that always made century 21 great we
adopted to change my friend I love you
love you too buddy good thank you so
much thank you for doing this fun show
for me fun to have guys like that on now
Andy que hay que leo
let's get into the show Sam ass is it
too cheap to bite off askgaryvee to
create ass Sam Gillan in the real estate
space to hustle for agent recruits I
love it Sam you could do whatever you
want I want the entire viewership of
this show to call it a show ask Tommy
Dee ask Leo Leo ask d-roc I don't care I
want to provide value bring that up from
value I don't feel like it's a ripoff
I'm not the first person to do a Q&A
show absolutely do it just make sure
that if you want to honor going that
route that you try to provide the value
that this show tries to provide to you
and so that if you're going to produce
and provide value to the real estate
space make sure it's in the best
interest of everybody who's watching and
that there is then some fall over some
sprinkles that lead to good things for
you then that's great but make sure the
energy is pure that would be the best
way to tribute not just because you want
to use it as a sales channel Jon ass
how can entrepreneurs avoid being soft
in business Jon I would argue that
entrepreneurs should be soft at business
I lead with my heart I made 13 decisions
today that were predicated not on the
dollars but on what made me feel good
what feels right and what the lifetime
value of that decision is how it's gonna
impact others so I think there's a
completely wrong point of view that you
need to be raw unemotional family
businesses don't stay in business for 54
years if they made just decisions on the
black-and-white bottom line I'm sure
what are some of longer tenured
employees over here get over here
let me give me some mishap employees for
26 27 years I mean and you don't get
there by just making black and white
financial decisions no I mean I assume
that you made tons of decisions that
didn't make the financial sense of that
moment we use common sense common sense
and we have a culture where people love
to work here they're all involved
everybody has an idea we listen to
everybody's idea and they make it
alright I think you're gonna keep
talking I'm gonna lose the show there
give me the Isaac show I'm gonna be out
of business get out of here I'm sorry
but I messed up the bottom line is
that's it guys you're not in business
for 54 years two generations three
generations you've got to make calls
that don't just lead with your with your
wallet it needs to come with your heart
I actually think the future of
entrepreneurship businesses that are big
will actually be considered soft by
today's standards because if you're
gonna go too hard there's too many
alternatives for people to do other
things than to work in that environment
as all these opportunities arise so I'm
a proud soft entrepreneur named Julie
Lowe says waiting for Jab Jab Jab right
hook to ship from Amazon and asked does
your theory still work in the Italian
market man Gio thank you so much does it
work in the Italian market does giving
giving giving and then ask work in the
Italian market doesn't provide value
provide value provide value and then
build equity and leverage to get
something in return does that work in
the Italian market it works in the human
market obviously every market is a
little bit different and they're
suppressed governments and there's
dynamics communism creates different
behaviors you know there's a million
different variables but at the end of
the day humans absolutely respond to
being guilted or feel compelled to
return favors or do good for people that
give good to them so when you're
providing value upfront whether you're
in Italy or Egypt or the Soviet Union
Syria Afghanistan Argentina New Zealand
it's going to work it's not going to
work on everybody do I believe there's
cultures countries that there's more
upside within based on the DNA and the
overall stereotypes of a country I do I
absolutely do but in general this is an
absolute winning formula not to mention
that it's a winning formula for you not
just your results you need to feel good
providing upfront value you know I'm not
gonna go I'm not gonna judge my life on
how much money I made I'm gonna judge my
life on how many people showed up to my
funeral and so the process works for me
not just on the financial aspect but on
who I want to be as a human being and
you need to ask that question for you I
you says hi Gary you told me in a
previous video that students should
never take a low to study
entrepreneurship what should they do
instead I believe that if you go to
college and collect debt to be an
entrepreneur not a doctor not a lawyer
not a consultant at deiner McKinsey
where you have to go to an Ivy League
school graduate and leverage that but a
true entrepreneur like like father and
brother go out there and hustle start
Merck be a merchant you know that to me
is a crazy proposition to collect debt
for in a twenty sixteen world so what I
think they should do instead is go work
literally just go work I mean think
about it instead of going $80,000 in
debt you can go work for a dollar and be
way up into the pot you can work for
free and be on the way positive and
speaking of that that speaks to my next
strategy go work for somebody and a
woman that you admire the way she did it
and take a lot less money working in her
organization than somebody else because
you're trying to SAP the IP out of her
out of that leadership so not only go
work go work for the lowest possible way
you couldn't survive go live with four
roommates in a studio apartment any fast
food if you have to you can go lose that
weight later like I did the bottom line
is you need to go work in an environment
that inspires you and wants and really
you want it to be a place that you want
to be like to go work for somebody that
you want to be like is it tremendous
value proposition for an entrepreneur
when I think about what Andy and d-roc
have been affected by through osmosis
they're probably scared to think about
some of the tendencies they now have
that are my tendencies because I'm
affecting it it's crazy how it works
it's crazy you should see the ego all
600 people at vaynermedia walking around
with it's disgusting but the bottom line
is it's affected from the top so go work
for somebody you admire want to
replicate and regardless of the cost if
you're a true entrepreneur
elite sports tipster ass if you were
starting in I needed to make 2k a month
and as few hours as possible what would
you do if I was starting again and I had
to make $2,000 as quickly as possible
what would I do without all the brand
equity I have obviously right it's funny
usually I say go to a garage sale I'm
gonna say I'd probably go to century 21
buy stuff and flip it on eBay on the
arbitrage because there's such a
discounter or Wine Library and return
the wine to another store that charges
more for it deep down the joke is and
I'm making a fun joke garage saleing
goodwill I'm a merchant buying something
for less than what I can sell it for is
what I'm really good at with no money
with not a lot of money and I have to
make 2k the quickest arbitrage I know in
today's society is to go to places buy
it and flip it on eBay the speed is very
quickly that was literally what I would
do I know my strengths if I always have
to build up again you know imagine I did
fail I made some critical mistakes and
lost everything first I would have to
rectify my family situation but then I
make a lot of money and have had a lot
of success of being right for the last
20 years that's what I live off of if I
was then to be so crazy wrong that I
went out of business I would no longer
be able to rely on my advice as my
foundation so I'd have to go back to the
way I'd built in the first place which
is truly sales selling stuff deep down
I'm a Salesman you know the truth is I
need to spend more time and I encourage
you vaynernation ask me more sales
questions because I think I have a lot
more to offer publicly around sales this
show has allowed me to talk a lot more
about HR management leadership the one
category where I think I've
disproportionately underserviced my
community is a lot more about my sales
skills which were really the
disproportional skills that grew Wine
Library while the technology was
catching up and so even the first year
of Wine Library went from three to nine
million just because I was on the floor
so yeah I would say that sales
cent that's a wrap very special episode
Isaac thank you so much for being on the
show I really appreciate it
if and when you visit New York City come
downtown come and check this out it's an
amazing amazing story that business
itself I know how many of you are
business people but the mural if you're
in town over the next two months
statement a day you know I don't want to
make it somber but you know a lot of you
were young but any comments on that very
tough day in American history any of
your shorts you know stories to share
with everybody else I think we all
remember where we were if we remember
that day be nice to come you know be a
community and talk about it a little bit
very special episode for me means a lot
to me very tough day for a lot of us
that grew up in this area so thanks for
watching I hope you enjoyed it you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them